hi I'm Matt this is my husband Patrick
this is my hubby's famous otoscope oil
or chicken and rice buddy we're very
Spanglish family but we pretty much only
call it chicken rice probably like 12 is
how much we talk at this little my
grandma makes this every year for
Christmas Eve that's our big Christmas
celebration with my family obviously you
can take it off using the fork of the
night I personally like the texture of
shredding it by hand rip it up yeah we
have to sit around the table and do this
with her oh did she put you to work as a
little kid
oh I mean all of us have been taught a
trick that you put in one grain of rice
and if it easily moves around then the
oils hot enough to put in the rest so
the pocket dances just like getting the
rice perfect is the hardest part should
I be stressed I mean obviously other
dishes come and go but there's always
two things
my uncle's margaritas and my grandma's
right and I've had the margaritas but
this would be my first time heavy
excited so now we've gone from the light
brown to the golden brown which means
we're ready to put in this house okay I
got this
so I think I really nailed that you can
obviously use a measuring cup to put in
the water but she actually was using
nifty little trucky of refilling the
saucepan twice and then I'm about at
much water a chinois nice I'm so hungry
the smells amazing
I know I skipped lunch would you do that
because I know this but this was gonna
take a while Wow
I can't believe I haven't shared this me
yeah you know I feel like it's official
now the abbeys chicken and rice she adds
in a few things that you would
traditionally see in an obstacle boil
dish but she has peas and carrots in
there and really it started because she
just wanted to add an extra color I've
kind of happy that we waited until we
were the husband kind of makes it even
more special but like now you're really
part of the club oh so cute I feel like
I'm getting closer to him by
experiencing everything he's grown up
with that he's learned from his family
[Music]
I need to make them right
that's my fruit dance it's a nice 100
yes
[Music]
[Music]